how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and although we
haven't really gotten anything from
marvel officially in a very long time
marvel studios has in fact opened again
sadly due to the pandemic they've had to
close down
they halted production on all of their
current projects but they have now
started up again
which means that we should get some type
of news from marvel studios soon whether
that's
leaks or anything official and today we
have a little bit of news about the
black
widow film and whether or not it's going
to go to video on demand or whether or
not it will still be in theaters
and we also have some news about the
hawkeye series there's been a casting
call that could reveal
the villain of the show or at least one
of the villains that they have planned
so i'll break down everything that you
need to know in this video but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu updates and a big congratulations to
zach
templeton for being the winner of last
week's funko pop giveaway
just email me in the email in my about
me section and we'll get you your prize
and this week we're giving away a
deadpool versus cable funko pop so all
you have to do is subscribe
like this video and leave a comment down
below to enter so first things first
everybody is still wondering whether or
not black widow is going to go into
theaters or go
on video on demand on disney plus new
service premier access
mostly everybody knows by now that mulan
is not going to be going to theaters
it's going to go straight to streaming
on disney's premiere access for
29.99 now although nothing official has
come out yet from disney there has been
something very interesting that has
happened
black widow has been listed on the video
on demand
service movies anywhere now it also has
listed mulan for its actual release date
september 4th
now i've been getting a lot of questions
about this and this very well could be
automated meaning the streaming service
could simply upload any upcoming movie
that is coming out
however if that were the case they would
probably list black widow for may 1st
and not
its new date of november 6th so it's
probably not automated but of course it
could be
a mistake they could have simply put it
up by accident but at the same time this
could be
very intentional and perhaps they know
something that we do not know
perhaps black widow is getting ready to
go on video on demand on disney's
premier access
and they know before we do mulan was
supposed to be a very big movie for
disney and they decided to go straight
to video on demand for mulan so they're
definitely considering doing it for
disney and perhaps they've already made
up their mind and this video on demand
service knows before we do
but unfortunately we can't know for sure
so for those of you who have been asking
you just have to sit tight for a little
bit longer
but in the meantime we do have some
really great information about the
hawkeye series
it appears that one of the main villains
of the show has been revealed
it's been reported in the past that the
hawkeye series is going to have
six episodes in its first season and now
we have a casting call for a character
that is going to appear in five to six
episodes meaning he is going to be part
of the main cast
the casting call is for a character code
named
eric and that's a wreck as in a-r-e-k
this character is described as a male 20
to 30 years old and having an eastern
european
background and although this character
is not confirmed yet most of us know who
it probably is
and that character is most likely
kazimierz kazemerzak
he's a young polish man who takes on the
persona of
clown in marvel comics now in the comics
clown is an assassin and he's hired by
numerous villains like kingpin to go and
take out hawkeye
now something really important to note
is that sometimes in the comics
hawkeye is deaf he's deaf in more than
one occasion in the comics he regains
his hearing but then something happens
and he goes deaf again
and the villain clown is responsible for
him going deaf one of those times
in the comics clown stabs hawkeye in
both of his ears with
arrows this causes him to go death once
again so this could be a plan for the
hawkeye series we might
see this play out on screen hawkeye
going deaf there have also been rumors
that the casting of ekko
in the hawkeye series has begun and the
character echo is also connected to
hawkeye being deaf as well
so it looks like our buddy clint barton
may be in for a pretty big surprise in
the hawkeye series and may have some
problems with this new upcoming enemy
clown especially if he's going to be
appearing in practically every episode
of the series
but let me know what you think about
this news what would you think if
hawkeye became deaf in the hawkeye
series and of course let me know if you
would rather see black widow in theaters
or
on disney plus on video on demand let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest
mcu news don't forget to follow me on
instagram and twitter for live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof